[Musique]
ok ok ok tu escalettes au québec makan
voc wac
[Musique]
quand
m
[Musique]
alors
alors j'ai remarqué que beaucoup
d'instagram heures
photographier ou filmer
ce qu'ils mangeaient ce qu'ils avaient
dans leur assiette avant de manger alors
j'ai pas trop compris l'intérêt je vais
faire pareil là par exemple je restais
des brochettes de poulet donc je voulais
montre dont
et alors est ce que ça change le goût
ah ouais ça change le goût de savoir que
des milliers de gens l'ont regardé ça
change complètement le goût je comprends
qu'on prenne en photo ce qu on va
bouffer autant pour moi
voilà un pool et où on a vu qu'est ce
que c'est bon
mamadou kanouté oui oui
oui voilà oui oui